have you ever been on a date in Tripoli
we had marks chips guac and burritos
I did not have sex afterwards oh oh yeah
no no one has sex after Chipotle
I loved your phone like so much I
[ __ ] love it I love Chipotle like
Oprah loves bread my ass loves Tripoli I
could eat your boy every day and I have
done that for weeks before I am hope
these will be good it already smells
delish it already smells like classic
Chipotle smell do we okay I have been
craving a burrito so bad there's a layer
of cheese
where on the whole outside there's rice
there's there's a lot of rice the guys
out there so smart oh I don't know I
like the cheesiness around it that's
kind of cool
let's visit so damn delicious
combination more of this all right this
is the burrito that you eat and then
like you just feel like you're gonna
birth that burrito later it tastes like
normal Chipotle I feel like it's more
just like the knowledge that you're
getting extra cheese feeling it now
nachos what is a real nachos you're not
supposed to do this you want talking
about beauty my girlfriend in this dish
right here I mean this is so basic why
would I eat [ __ ] every life oh I like a
brilliant that's good
oh my god delicious yes practical nah
it's pretty standard nachos I do like
the combination I like I need a gallon
of waters off mm-hmm it's really salty
what is this little nugget what in the
world is this I've never seen anything
this drama kapolei anytime you put
something at photos always like a damn
surprise oh okay
follows oh that's no bull taco visit let
I hate this letter oh and there's look
there's a layer of cheese in between
those which pull a secret menu is
apparently just adding cheese two things
I think I'm kind of lactose intolerance
so this is gonna be an interesting day
like the bread is not the best part it's
pretty good you're looking off
yeah the tortilla I think I'm just
eating cheese but I like it too much
cheese to bready lots of cheese I'm not
gonna be able to poop later a sad person
would make this yeah break up food this
was melted and a layer of the hot sauce
is melted onto it was an actual case of
year that would be golden that case of
burrito though genius I like that yeah
that was very innovative I told y'all I
like to hold am I you know bring your
next date to a triple and I see how that
goes home lay is delicious and actually
not the understanding wish tuple there
was a man aren't above would mean